The
next
excerpt is taken from original tape W one fifty two.
When
I was growing up did you have to work with
your.
I Pad and phone. But
you know.
I was out of religious cotton and going to Harvard that's what my years
but when I was born
but
no
now.
We want to raise cotton.
When they don't exist yet in a way. What a
big man John and slid out you know but also most
of the stone wall in my
hood and the rest of the past and So Cal of the stuff you know
raising one man I had four or five want to go to the scene working in seventy
one chap one fact that.
Sam would not want to be in love with run my own
country but to call somebody good on that Jemma what it was tell an adult a big man.
You know if you had the money you know what I want to say.
Back to the small
man. Of fifteen or twenty thousand not a little old man upset
about commodity. You want to sell them on
bass machine I'm about ten when I
first you buy all of it right to go on the run and. That said
I will be paid for
that
book I don't want to stand that work when you are a logger I mean you go out of the
Jones reason I have seen you run by you tell me your government to learn from
the SELL SELL
I'm not all that good you can just go and
you know known for planning incredible shoulder looking play
for I have one
Bush put to the time with one night because you are high priestess on
the photos of Bush that it had a credit card pushed him now and overall
I had to come out couldn't run the ten or where David Temple made with anything else
I'm not a put into bullshit I haven't known him all my life. As I know myself.
Well you know you are to the saw me only
a
kilometer with the reason I wrote what I make my this is a
runaway from a took over on oh I had to come to him as
a loser him to get to the government and I put two in the bushes in a row when
I brought it was all right with some to the bush at the time I cut him
down
no wonder you wrong the wrong way to go to
teach one woman that. That is some not so the
problem is now you have got to be
conned Yeah you got it both chemical IMO but I don't hide my view by September I
know why if you go by you when you came by I had to move
it but to me you have to move about it. And
I want to man I never thought of was man a man before self you
know small never want to talk to one
of them sell me stuff follow the law for four
twelves sum it up by then so much thousand a movie.
Who do not see
them who use them they don't buy the timber sell them like Java sit.
Seven rocks. And pay them so much about the
movie CD about a modest one hundred thousand I will tell my one.
Coming about it
Jim and pay them so much as the movie.
Title would they have until they
got popped on I'm A full
well
know my mom. Well I'm still a lot of
friends you know I got a note of.
No fact.
Some of them you work you could work for somebody else could you like if you didn't have your
own truck so. Oh yeah he was one of my you won't pay much.
If you work all year round as a seasonal
thing. But I love it here on sale so I don't
want to do if you got your own
temperament or a job or signified what you consider nobody else but
then. Have a lot of a
few
don't quit with their own will but I met a few and you got to
see who back to can hold in the Bible now but I won't like
that Ramallah job I run in myself so
I
didn't do
that and put a towel in a lot of manmade good and
bad as well step up and he won't put it out and I will tell him about a fifteen thousand of all by himself.
They don't
hate exactly my meaning make Rayman a good money place that my value.
Put
well as anybody else.
About able to do that without going about it in the kind of money about three or
four
places bunch of challenge and make good money.
But this was a live man out of it.
If you all alone. Imagine if you guys don't solicit own.
You know
who might if you had a hole in the
medieval that
don't don't you know what I mean to claim. It's
just but if the big man is backing them up in this case I'm
all rocks not
just backing him up as he owns
the claim of but now I'm taking what I
know I'm a session id really expensive I want it now
and
that's a lot of people just look to the white man if they're only going
to can but I know that and. I want to have that sale farmer
need.
You all so you come to a certain place. Tell
him used to be used to turn around and know what you want now you know to do
a white
man not
then if you
do that could fall or not and I matter. I
had gotten a name and you know what you are you doing all
of you did all the farming all right is all about
expense you buy your fertilizer Paul you do all of what you ought to have in it and you have a you
know we
call and when I did that God made me Jan you all are just gin and then
they lit up and when that man status you got rid
of sentiment echoed back and
my home.
You go to him and him tell you what I want to tell
you that will hit if they want to give a one hundred two thousand a year and give it to you.
And if you didn't. And then tell
you that you didn't get any money
because that was in looking if you was
good for the first time and yes that's
right
yes but they give you a very minimum amount of out of
a question. I mean then I'm not going to
fail and it didn't make a because you may not have them I dated.
I did a town my date of May
sixteenth. Before I
would have you make that cotton and no man would call no man look
for a man that was he has on a list of what we call
the land a land of brightness look for we want to avoid in order one day
price we call negative
and we were satisfied because they made him a maid came for
about fifty or fifty you take a wrong
way I want
to buy a
comeback in case but I don't want
to see that in my career.
I want to buy that kind of car we have to go and you better take it over
to what would you have you got that.
Your dad is going to make for some of the day.
Some of the money. So
we can have a big money do you remove your FREE.
Some cold wind and then take from when you
go to some calling for me and we
school number. Not on
Monday and they will either rise in the budget.
Never have been of any worth while I was taken by my man like
that and made a muscle you could stay for all the sea
potatoes going by a little bit and
you
know my whole modern way and a lot
of you take foreign fighters that were given the money.
We wanted to call Want
to the cattle you didn't. My grandma was right it was
I'm a phony alone
for forty two years ago or ten years ago.
My grandma IMO and white folks are honest.
Never mind grandma all day and I want to play with
why what she did my husband will never make a
man taken
from me mate or did he take my
grandma or she what you want my friend it was a man ahead
of him to go
girl to my mandible good man
somebody there for good measure and he's right in the night I come out I
don't get up out of my
past and that's where he got started and wouldn't my
master for I know my whole family and have a
kayak here and know about
no I didn't run folks
here noted by no massa forward and miles
around and then the food you're just another fool and
shouted and none want to
go and week out come out later and get him off
helpful for three or four years ago and raise a bunch of amount of NO
to takin my grandad and start him
off. One of their grandchildren
had hundreds and hundreds.
I'm not going to give them a kick I'm tell you what to do You did it and they say they don't mind out to the PM so
may want to thank them to die. Every now and then to do it and not do it to everyone in there to
have to look at them you
know because then I get a day IMO
and one of the home with a gun.
You can't demand they
have to find a time out or down run a scotch.
But alas fortify you by the moment but have you remember the whole I
know that
we need to hear
rough you make sense of the day of a
money maker so they were to man the wrecking ball didn't come up with me. They want
to know
what I've found out a half of my Mama was in work
all my life. And to give me a look to do the
life because only one time some have time for the next
you know the hand that no I don't want to know I'm back but from the moment of
attention I couldn't go to school they wanted to
go get a crab.
I already have that's why. I'm not a maid was a new mother. We
have lost a lot of them own little farm and they feared to get
the money from the white cotton on the C.
drive
of their one night truck first year. If we could stay there and we all get
money you want us to stay to get his money back with his wife with him.
My father knew what it was about big
ones for my mother when
I let loose told him what to do. They worked
oh here you want to go. Come back up their ass very
like women used to
have me
on my own much
of the ravening
unintended by about. Sixty years ago
not specific I mean the fifty years voted on the right to keep
them and
then nobody nobody
at a
rough moment.